today we're going to look at the rook
and the rook is one of the most powerful
pieces of digital come across the rook
is worth five pause now let's go ahead
and take a look at how the rook moves
the rook is going to move vertically and
horizontally is many moves as he can now
if there's a piece in his way he's not
going to be able to do that so let's go
ahead and put a piece in the way let's
say there's a pawn here now instead of
going the entire way we can move all the
way to a five we can move all the way to
h5 we can move all the way down to d1
but we can't move back to d8 like we
could before the only as far as we can
go we can capture on these six but we
can't hop over pieces the rook can go
horizontally and vertically as long as
there's no pieces in the way as you can
imagine we want the rook to have as much
space to roam as possible so if you look
at a chessboard and you think about
what's the best way for a rook to act
right now at the beginning of a
chessboard the rook has nowhere to move
now let's go ahead and remove one of our
pawns at the beginning you can already
tell right away our rook has a lot more
room to move in there says now this is
not to say that you should start your
chess games without pawns you never want
to be down a material if you can't
avoid it but that is to say that the
rook is always going to be wants to be
in open files so let's say you have you
know an open file on you know the C
square if you have you know your C
square and let's say let's say your
setup is something like this you have an
open C file meaning you don't have a
pawn blocking you now want to bring your
rook to c1 because you want your rook to
have as much line that he can travel as
you can now obviously once we move our
night out of the way on c3 our works
going to have a long horizontal vertical
line that he can go and this another
thing you want to know about rooks is
they are involved in castling and Caston
is very important one because it gives
you King safety but two it's the only
time in chess where two pieces move the
King moves in the rook move so let's go
ahead and take a look what that looks
like
let's go and look at this position right
here castling looks like this you can
see right now our King is kind of out in
the open and we can castle either King
side or Queen side and it looks that you
move your king over twice and your rook
hops over and that's one move right
there it's called castling or you can do
Queen side you move over twice and the
rook hops over some people get confused
and try to move their King over to be
one which is three moves that's an
illegal move it's two spaces to each
side so either it's g1 or 2 c1
it's called King side or Queens outer
short side or long side however you hear
that's what it is it's castling
now there's four rules that you have to
keep in mind when it comes to castling
the first one is none of the pieces
can have moved before so if you look at
this position right here the rooks have
obviously moved since they started mhm
one day one they've already moved so
there's no castling in this position
even if the rooks move back to h1 you
can't Castle because they've already
moved as well as if your King moves you
can no longer Castle another thing you
want to look at is is there a peace
between so if you look at the position
with let's say a knight in between I
know the Knights are Thunder you won but
let's say there's a piece in between you
can't castle on this side you can still
Castle queenside if you want let's see
if I can have it let me here that's
white smooth you can still Castle
queenside but you can't Castle kingside
because there's a piece in the way so
that's the second one the third that the
third one that you want to look at is if
you're in check let's take a look at
this position in casting let's say
Bishop moves Bishop to b4 now we're in
check now we would like to Castle
queenside obviously we can't Castle
kingside because our Knights in the way
but let's say we want a Castle queenside
that would be awesome because we can one
get our rook into the game and to put
our king and safety but we can't castle
because we're in check this is another
thing you want to think about in chess
now what we can do is we can play let's
say c3 and then when the bishop moves
now we're no longer in check now we can
Castle queenside this is something to
think about and the last and
the fourth thing to think about when
castling is let's say instead of putting
us in check he plays a move like Bishop
to g4 now he's not attacking our king
and if we Castle we're gonna end up on
c1 but our king is going to move through
the d1 and since the d1 squares in our
attack we cannot castle now what we can
do here kind of like before is we can
block that and once he moves now the d 1
square is no longer under attack and now
we can castle but if the square we don't
even have to be in check and it we don't
even have to end up on the square that's
under attack if the square that we go
through is under attack
we can't castle so those are just some
of the things that you want to think
about with your rook 1 they're very
helpful for cancelling but 2 you always
want to have your rooks on open files so
that they can move if they're always
trapped behind your pieces it's really
not going to be as valuable because they
can't move around and although they are
worth 5 points if they're always blocked
you're not going to get any benefit out
of it so hopefully you learned a lot
from this and go out and use it in your
own chess game